so I actually read quite a lot of
non-fiction books this year well 12 to
be precise and here are my thoughts on
each of them as you may be interested in
reading them yourself or to give them to
use your sciency friends for Christmas
and I'll try and present them in the
order that I read them so I began the
year with the case against reality how
Evolution hit the truth from our eyes by
Donald Hoffman this book wasn't what I
expected which is what I wrote on the
inside cover of this book was just
somewhat fitting given this book is a
lot about our perceptions versus reality
and questions what reality is and isn't
and what I mean by that is Donald
discusses in great depth about how we
sense the world around us and our brain
senses and processes different stimuli
and why you should take your perception
seriously but not literally now
shockingly I haven't made deep notes
from my highlights after reading this
despite the fact it was the first book
of the year that I read but I remember
enjoying it at the time at least the
first half and I would reread it if I
didn't already have a massive lineup of
books to read so just by not fairly
documenting or remembering the details
when I finished it I gave it a 4 out of
five
so that's good
all right so next up is the music of
Life by Dennis Noble and this book
Dennis considers the system level view
of life as music and uses the metaphor
to ask the questions where is the score
and who is the composer if there is a
program of life
I picked this book up from the library
after a spontaneous trip while waiting
for the bike shop to fix my flat tire
and I'm glad I did it was very easy to
read well written thought for faking and
I would highly recommend it anyway the
theme of this book is that there is no
such program the DNA sequence isn't The
Book of Life sure it's where the
information is encoded but life works
also due to information not found in DNA
and It ultimately ends up discussing the
different levels by which we can view
life and introduce us the readers to
systems biology
and that there is no privilege level of
causality and biological systems and so
since I mentioned system is biology
later in a year I read a very short
introduction to systems biology by
Eberhart Floyd I made a separate video
discussing what I thought were the most
interesting Concepts in this book so
I'll keep it short here the small book
is a good introduction to systems
biology essentially the use of
computational tools and Theory to
analyze and simulate biological
processes and see how chaotic behaviors
can come from seemingly simple systems
now the second book I picked up in the
spontaneous Library trip was the contact
Paradox by Keith Cooper which caught my
eye because of the cover and also
because I really quite like the film
contact anyway I love this book and I
felt very cool to be seen reading it in
various places well not that I really
needed the book for that but anyway this
book is indeed about searching for life
out there or messaging life so introduce
you to seti and meti projects and it
also introduced me to Concepts such as
Dyson spares but it is also much more
than that and discusses the altruism
hypothesis intelligence and I'm kind of
annoyed at myself for not making better
notes in it before I return it to the
library so I'll probably have to revisit
again uh next year
another book that I made a video in this
year is house buys think 10 lessons and
intelligence by David omandt which
describes essentially what the book is
about how to think logically and make
rational decisions David was former
director of the government
Communications Headquarters and applies
Knowledge from his time there to
illustrates the 10 different lessons
I found this book quite dense and would
have provided a more condensed summary
plus I didn't feel like I have seen much
of a difference in terms of my decision
making since reading a book but that
said I mean I don't think it's trivial
to apply some of the lessons that he
tells you but I do think it is quite an
interesting book and you may still
really enjoy all the details maybe it
just wasn't so much for me
now as you may have guessed I've been
trying to expand my horizons this year
of my reading lists and one book that
helps me remember much of my physics a
level was fundamentals 10 keys to
Reality by Frank walchek another library
book so I can't actually physically show
you it gave me similar Vibes to the
contact Paradox probably because they
both talk a lot about space but this was
another book that I thoroughly enjoyed
here Frank talks about space time atoms
quantum physics and at the end human
perception which brought back memories
of reading Donald Hoffman's book
actually
actually take that back he answered
complimentarity and what level's
description are sufficient or optimal to
understand the system be that how to fly
a hot air balloon or understand the
human body
it was fundamentally an interesting book
now one book I enjoyed reading this year
was the future of the minds by Michio
Kaku the last of the library books I
think
um I feel like I read this book around
early summer at the same time I was
re-watching all the stranger things
ahead of the new series coming out and
why did I bring that up well this book
covers many topics about how our minds
work Minds control secret government
experiments they were conducted and
obviously has references and connections
to stranger things and the sort of
powers that they possess anyway I'm
still currently making my deep notes in
this book and we'll have to say the
references could be better but still
nonetheless very interesting and maybe
at some point I will make a video on
this this book
all right so then I read the end of
everything which sounds a little bit
depressing written by Katie Mark a
theoretical astrophysicist who studies
Dark Matter black holes and early Galaxy
formation
so as you may have guessed this book is
about the end of everything and by that
I mean everything and discusses the
different ways in which the universe can
end but to understand how the world
could end you have to understand how the
world began and it also has some nice
figures to illustrate her different
views now I gave this book a bit of a
lower Mark partly because I think I
didn't learn as much and that was
probably my fault because I just read to
space books previously uh so yeah but
still a good book
now at some point during the summer I
decided to watch the film radioactive a
film about the life of Marie Curie which
was interspersed with later life events
such as schnabble and Hiroshima and I
suddenly had this mad Panic that what if
I discovered something that later led to
something really bad and anyway long
story shorts I came across this book
biological weapons to see if I could
learn anything that may help me in my
sort of dilemma process frankly I don't
think it did
um but it did give me a very in-depth
historical perspective of what has
already happened in terms of biological
weapon testing in different countries
and the consequences of that now this
book came out in 2005 so it's a little
bit healthy date now and was actually
written by the late Gene Gilman
um deceased wife of the famous
biochemist Matthew musselton who was
actually heavily involved in enforcing
regulations on Anthrax usage in the
states
there's a very dense and detailed book
and personally I really struggled to
read a set of times but again I can
imagine some people would really like
this definitely be like cup of tea
um but yeah I would really hope that
someone makes some sort of like updates
book on biological weapons or
biosecurity that's definitely a book
that I feel like is uh Missing in the
markets
anyway after that in one afternoon I
decided to read this little book called
cryobiology now despite being a slow
reader I managed to read it in an
afternoon because well it might be aimed
at children but sometimes if you want a
beginner's introduction to something you
have to take baby steps and that's what
I did it's engaging approachable
straight to the point loads of pictures
it is quite outdated to be fair and I
have already made a video on this topic
the other week so maybe you want to
check that out otherwise I don't think I
would recommend buying it unless you
have kids who would probably enjoy it
um it was just more for my own personal
entertainment let's put it that way
right and so next I read this book
called bio future confronting the
genetic era by Burke Zimmerman and I
loved reading this book because the copy
I ended up getting was a black card back
and it kind of looked like I was reading
Tom Riddle diary it was just um but
anyway in all seriousness it was a very
interesting read the book came out in
1984 and I feel lucky to sort of have a
copy of this um which I got a second
hand off Amazon
anyway as part textbook part Popular
Science and well as Amazon describes
this causes human cell structure genetic
engineering clones the biotechnology
industry and the possible benefits and
dangers of genetic experiments cool
right and despite coming out almost 40
years ago it's discussing topics that
are still very relevant today
I can't say much more than that because
I definitely need to go back over my
notes in this one so again hold out for
that and also hold out because I
literally just finished reading a book
this week called the biological Time
Bomb which is in many ways very similar
to uh biofuture
again a very old book this time written
by Gordon rat Ray Taylor who actually
the national Sciences at Cambridge a
long time before me though um and then
he entered a career of scientific
journalism
and this book actually came out in 1968
to even older and to be fair my own
current impression is that this book was
far less heavy on the science
discoveries and more based on Rat Race
assumptions that they were inevitably
occur and these include things such as
longevity organ transplants IVF mind
control genetic editing and more and
then he considers the emotional
Financial moral and social problems that
come with it
now in both these books the biological
time bomb and by your future they
definitely had some sort of ideas and
Concepts that I don't think I 100 agreed
with but I don't think that's you know
sometimes is a good thing to hear other
people's perspectives but I haven't
actually physically gone back through
with the fan came to sort of digest what
I read in both these bookshots so I
can't really say much more but other
than the fact that it was quite
interesting to read these old books and
has become a weird Niche thing that I
enjoy doing now so uh yeah that's that's
that's that
um so it turns out I read some
interesting books to share
and it's been good fun revisiting them
to make this video and many of which I
know I still have to revisit to make
some more notes um probably while I
procrastinate writing my thesis anyway I
hope that's given you some books to add
to your reading list let me know what
you read this year because oh well I
didn't really need any more books to add
to my reading list but maybe others do
and to be fair I like to to see other
people's recommendations so with that I
hope you have learned something on this
video thank you to my patreon supporters
and thank you for listening